another chef sinker for the ultimate
Christmases keep your menu balance in
the restaurant we work incredibly hard
to get the perfect balance of flavors
textures and richness in every meal and
the same is true for getting it right at
home so over Christmas were you dolt and
a lot of rich food is crucial you have
some night dishes that we sleep to
really balance it out
[Music]
Salizar the perfect antidote to
overextending bellies at Christmas but I
don't have to be virtuous Affairs you
can save that one for your new year's
resolution I'm going to show you my
secret for turning salad nicoise into a
dish dramatic and delicious enough to
marry a place in any Christmas
celebration it sounds a real big hit in
our household over Christmas it's
delicious so versatile and tastes
absolutely amazing now we're gonna do a
delicious salmon Nicoise which is a
really nice way of reinvigorating your
taste buds across Christmas first of all
when I post this and a really nice
fragrant court boolean called boolean is
just a fancy name for poaching liquor
first add fennel with his lovely Amity
flavor to water then put in chopped
celery onions and salt next pour in some
white wine to give it some body
add a splash of tarragon vinegar to give
it bite that wakes up everything that
really makes it sort of slightly acidic
but more importantly there's brilliantly
well with a salmon to add flavor pop in
a couple of star anis and crush white
peppercorns
for freshness and zing put in a handful
of parsley a couple of bay leaves and a
sliced lemon
[Music]
then bring the liquid up to the boil and
slip in the salmon
no need to season it because the water
called boolong is all seasoned
beautifully slip that in nice and gently
skin side down
salmon's sweet delicate and incredibly
flavor something now to go even higher
than terms of flavor simmer the salmon
for four to five minutes then turn it
off and let it cool down in the liquid
you